The Tallest Man Ever... and 9 other Amazing
Records
1.
The tallest man in history was Robert Pershing
Wadlow, who was 8 feet 11.1 inches (2.72 m)
tall and 485 pounds at the time of his death.
By the age of 4 years old, he was already
5 ft 4 inches tall (1.63m).
At the age of 13, he became the tallest boy
scout in history at 7 ft 4 inches (2.24m).
Wadlow had not yet stopped growing at the
time of his death at the age of 22.
He died in 1940 of an infection caused from
blisters on his ankle that he didn’t notice
at first due to not being able to feel much
of anything in his feet and lower legs.
2.
The Most Peeps ever eaten by one person in
a half an hour is 102, done by Dennis Gross
in 2003.
It should be noted that in official “Peep-offs”
(Peep eating competitions), in order to keep
from being disqualified, you must eat your
vomit if you throw up the Peeps at any time
during the competition.
People have done this.
3.
The record for the most wooden toilet seats
broken by a human head in 60 seconds is 46,
done by Kevin Shelley in 2007.
4.
President Martin Van Buren was technically
the first “American” President in that
he was the first to be born an America citizen,
as opposed to being born English or the like.
He also is the first U.S. President not to
be of English or Irish ancestry.
His ancestors were Dutch.
5.
Joey Chestnut of Stockton, California once
won $1,500 by eating 8.8 pounds of fried asparagus
in just 10 minutes.
6.
The world record for the most rotations in
60 seconds while suspended in the air holding
a power drill is 148, achieved by The-Huy
Giang in 2008.
7.
The most weight ever lifted by a human tongue-
by sticking a metal hook through a hole in
the tongue to hook to the weights- is 27 pounds
and 8.96 oz (12.5 kg), performed by Thomas
Blackthorn in 2008.
8.
At the Vidalia Onion Festival, a man named
Russ Wagner once won $100 by eating 10 whole
raw onions.
9.
The record for the most spoons balanced on
a human face is 17, done by Aaron Caissie
of Canada.
10.
The most concrete blocks broken while holding
an unbroken raw egg in the hand that broke
the blocks is 24, accomplished by Joe Alexander
of Germany.
11.
The U.S. state with the most lawyers per capita
is Washington D.C., which boasts about 277
lawyers for every 10,000 residents.
This is nearly 14 times more lawyers per 10,000
than any other state in the United States
(New York being the runner up).
The lowest lawyer rate per capita is North
Dakota with around 4 lawyers per 10,000 people.